my name is Alan Schechter and I am a
consultant to the NIH history office and
on behalf of Chris Ryan Jack and Chris
Donahue and others from the Jeff Resnick
from the history program I'd like to
welcome you all to the special lecture
by Professor Pascal grizzee on the
history of the inserm
institution in France
um the title
the title of Professor Jose's talk is
biomedical research in France and is
institutionalization between 1940 and
1970 and there's an abstract of his talk
on the NIH uh calendar events home page
Professor grize is president of the
scientific committee for the history of
inserm as well as a professor of modern
history at the Soban Institution
um he was trained as a business
historian I gathered from his CV but
he's been primarily interested in the
history of Enterprises in general uh in
particular with respect to Innovation
research policies and organizations
especially in France and in Europe more
generally
he has
edited a great number of magnificent
volumes related to these topics which
have been published in French Germany
German as well as in English fortunately
for me and these books include studies
of European technology patents
communication
uh the history of the French Academy of
Sciences and very recently the French
Academy of Medicine
but the one book that has uh had the
greatest impact on us and which has been
the basis for our interchange is the
book published five years ago called 50
years of inserm which is a beautiful
history of the interim organization and
my own personal hope is that the
National Institute of Health can within
a finite time generate a book of
comparable uh importance
and
attractive presentation
um
the
professor Chris visited to us today he's
accompanied by Dr Philip or Beth who is
the interim representative at the French
Embassy and we're glad to be able to
interact with him as well but let me now
not spend further time and turn you over
to Professor grissay
[Applause]
thank you very much Helen thank you very
much Christopher for organizing this uh
this third candle we are trying to do in
order to have a kind of convergence
between uh insom and NIH in term of uh
history I will try to present you today
a short presentation about the the
beginning of the interim I will go from
the
creation of the insom before the interim
during the second world war and I will
stop at the end of the 1970s when the
institution will be engaged in a new
period there is no fundamental
difference but I think that the interest
of the paper is more centered on that
as an a tradition I I will Begin by two
major figures of the history of Medicine
of in France
lineage
was presented as a kind of hero in the
French medicine Community
inventing the stethoscope I imagine it's
the same word in English and is there a
kind of error of the doctor close to the
patients working in the hospital and on
the other hand you have we pastor we
Pastor is the archetype of the
researcher is a kind of Legend in in
France but in many in many countries and
during a long-term perspective I will
say that the
characterize two type of
researchers who are engaged in the
progress for medicine linac is on the
bench sorry in the clinic and Pastor is
on the bench and you have this tension
between these two communities this
tension you can see it in the history of
Instagram I will not address it
completely today but you have to keep
this to keep that in mind I will
organize my token reports it's the way
we used to do that in in Southern
University
and the first part will go from work to
reconstruction
um the second world war
1939 1945 the second part will address
the evolution between the institutional
Degen
Asian National Institute to the creation
of incern and then we will see the uh
first part of the history of the
institution the the part when the
organization was really
finding its own way in a global
environment
based on political issues
scientific issues and different things
that we will see firstly from from war
to reconstruction I begin with this
picture of the sd2 pastor you uh I will
try many times in my talk to explain the
differences between the research was not
in the universities compared to the
United States you have no scientific
research in the French universities
before I will say
a very recent period the research was in
some Laboratories in the universities
but was not
developed like in the in the in the
United States for instance or in uh in
red or in Germany mostly
uh the by what we could call the bio
medical research was mostly uh in The
Institute pastor
the sdg pastor was created at the end of
the 19th century and was was based on
the on the private funding and uh this
situation was not uh standable as in the
after first world war and finally after
a long Evolution was created the Central
National scientific in 1939 which was
the the first organization of scientific
research in France and this institution
was supposed to address all the
different field of research
from I will say history to physics to
chemistry and so on
this date of the creation of the San
Andreas Is Not Innocent the uh
perspective of the War
uh was in the mind of the creators of
the of the seneres and unfortunately as
you as you know
1940 was a really terrible year for
France with the defeat
the beginning of the government of
Marshall Peter and on the other and the
development of a kind of resistance and
free friends who tried to
um to to to to to
keep friends in the on the on the
battlefield
so during the between 1940 and 1944 life
continued in France uh of course in a
very specific context but the government
of my shall Peter if you want to
understand the period you can divide it
into bars during the first part the
Marshall petan government was engaged
already in the collaboration with
Germany but
some groups of people were trying to
prepare
the period after the war some kind of
technocrats we imagine a new friends in
the future they were of course connected
to a national petan government but well
they were not connected directly to to
to Germany after 1942 that was different
for many reasons but you can find in
what was created by martial petan
government some positive elements some
positive Elements which were developed
later after the war and in the case of
research dealing with medicine that
question is very complex I will not
develop it but you will understand when
you will know that two institutions were
created by martial pitan government the
first one was the foundation francaise
politude the problem Zuma this
institution was created by Alexi carella
a Nobel Prize but very very very I will
say complex complex and contested
personality
supporting Jainism and connected
directly to this Vichy government the
fact is that Alex died in 1944 so he was
not presented to judges and this
institution finally was transferred in
the attitude nationality to demographic
an Institute dedicated to the history of
pop2d studies of population so you have
this first part of the of the
organization of medical research in the
in France not a lot of
development but I have to to underline
the connection between France and the
United States Alex had strong links with
the Rockefeller Foundation
the Radford Foundation played a huge
role in the development of French
medical research
the Rockefeller Foundation supported
Alexi Karel researches
Alex was linked also to Lindbergh and
they they worked together so you see
that to understand the political issues
the ideological issues of this period is
very complex so I mentioned this point
but I will not of course develop all the
complexity of this of this period
to come back more directly to Instagram
the very precise origin of in some is
the creation the of The Institute
National Legion the in November 1941.
this institution was mostly dedicated to
prison time problems
France was starving a lot of the food
was going to Germany the production of
food was not sufficient to feed the
population and this new institution was
supposed to help to find solution to
follow the health of the population and
to to check things but that was not the
only goal of this new institution the
goal was much more broader this was
really the creation of a kind of agency
dedicated to research in F Public Health
globally but also more precise subject
depending on the people we were engaged
in different projects
I pass quickly this institution was also
supported until 1941 by the Rockford
Foundation by a U.S money you have is
here a picture of the
center based in Marseille in the south
of France in this period Marseille was
not occupied by the Germans it was in
the non-occupied part of France it's a
little bit complex but so the the
cooperation between the Institute
National Legion and the Rockefeller
Foundation stopped when the German Army
entered in the sales button of France in
1942 but what you can see is that the
links between the United States Rockford
foundation and The Institute National
Legion where
based on a long-term perspective and
that the U.S Foundation was able to to
help friends to to develop This research
to be a nurse or honest is not the world
to be precise the level of This research
at this time was very low
The Institute Pastor was working on in
his in his part but globally the the
level of the research was very low
some reports were published by The
Institute National Legion
on the racial Valley we was at the head
of this institution was recognized at
the end of the war as a person who was
able to maintain the research to to work
for the Earth of France is what he was
not considered as a collaborator with
the chairman and you see him here
receiving a very high level medal from
the Lea in the in 1945.
you have to understand that the creation
of the astituational decision is the is
a part of a much more broad project
at the end of the of the war
when I said the end of the war I'm not
precise enough during the war and after
the war you have a continuity that could
be that could look strange but it's the
reality you have a continuity between a
Vichy government and the gold government
in terms of promoting the research in
terms of French Independence and
development of the country well
continuity is maybe a little bit too
much but you you you have a strong link
and you can see here that between 1941
and 1946 almost every year different
Institute big Institute for research
were created in France and the
institutional National Legion was in a
way the first one you can find
institution dealing with
telecommunication
with a steel with a nuclear with
Agriculture and so on so it's the first
wave of the development of French
research based on the on the state
impulse in Persia
the other point that we have to keep in
mind concerning the uh this period is
the creation of the Social Security it's
also a big difference between uh France
and this country uh
the fact that the social security was
created is that the Earth is not
completely and say completely back
because there is a private part of uh
the medical sector uh in France but
globally uh the Social Security created
a solidarity between the different uh
activities in the medical sector and
it's very good on the one hand because
for many reasons for the access to us
for a large part of the population but
on the other end that is a kind of
weight under development of knowledge of
new technology and so on because
somewhere in the in the brain and the
spirit of the of the of the government
there is always the fear that the
development of activities in the medical
sector will put a too heavy weight on
the shoulder of the Social Security so
you you the balance between the two
these two tenances is complex and you
have to to have that in mind wow we can
go now to my second part and see how
from the institution National Legion
created in 1941 confirmed in 1944 we
went to the creation of insert
um
the new director of the astitution
national Legion was rui Brunner Louis
Benigno took the direction of the
Institute and decided to uh go again in
the United States in order to find the
support of the Rockefeller foundation so
the links between the Rockefeller
foundation and I will say the French
medical community where obviously
developed again after The
Liberation liberation of France
and so the support of the Rockefeller
Foundation was very important important
on
um from a double perspective the first
one is that for different uh hospitals
or a small team of research Rockefeller
Foundation
gave Monet gave some specific equipments
coming from the United States it's not
the Marshall Plan but something like
that in the same Spirit to have friends
to recover and to develop a new new
activities you have to have in mind that
during five years
during a time when the anti-antibiotics
and so on were developed the French
Community was almost completely cut from
the international research from the
international Evolution so the help of
the Rockefeller Foundation was very
important in order to put the the the
friend medical community at I will say
acceptable level but the most important
part from my point of view was not there
at least in a long-term perspective the
Rockford Foundation allowed a a huge
number of young doctors to go to the
United States in order to learn new
methods to go into universities and you
have here a list of one of the most
important
researchers who were engaged in in
research postdoc PhD while I don't
remember exactly the the level of each
one by John doce
Alexander
Maurice tubiano will be the leaders of
French research in the in the future and
when I say leaders it's not only in
terms of medical research as a scientist
that they will be leaders of the
organization of research they will be
able to make the connection between the
political power and the scientific
community in order to create a new
organization to give to find money to
find organization to develop the the the
research and you see that between Boston
Chicago
um
and New York the
[Music]
um
the
connection were very important and these
are the most famous examples but of
course the group was much more important
I like this testimony of Maurice tubiano
who is in the uh in the in some archives
he he wrote later we discovered a new
medicine some perspective Minds liked
Dobrev or Boneyard had understood that
it was necessary to encourage young
Physicians to develop in the United
States in 1947 I was fortunate to be one
of them and I will I still have a
dazzling memory of those 14 months where
modern medicine was revealed to me and
what was important for Maurice to Vienna
is of course the knowledge the
technicity and so on but it's it was
also
the way he was able to work in a team
exchanging with the top leaders of the
Laboratories and so on at this time uh
the the the the French organization was
still very hierarchical with modahan
this kind of organization I'm not sure
it's finished I don't know but at the
this time it was really rigid and the
way to work was different in the U.S if
you look at the testimonies of other
people for instance in computer science
a little bit later they had the same
feeling it's the knowledge it's the
level of Science of course but they were
all already good but it's most
importantly this Spirit State of Mind
um
the question of money was very important
uh of course uh elastic institutional
Edition received money from the
government but the French government was
poor in the 1950s of course the
development of the country was quick and
that's the beginning of the Tron
glorious this period of huge uh uh
growth for the French economy but
because of the colonial wars mainly
France was engaged in the uh Indochina
War until 1954 and then in Algeria War
until 1960 162 and so a lot of money was
going into the war and the the the trip
of the Ministry of Finance in France was
to come in Washington in order to have
some money to to to for the Army so that
was not very positive and uh Jean
Bernard and jean-ambers which were which
we were already a great leader in the in
research and France decided to to create
a a kind of we could say Think Tank
in order to imagine the future of the
French medical reasons future in term of
organization but also in terms of
fundraising how to find money so they
organize different uh different tracks
in order to be connected to some
families to find money for their own
Laboratories but also to share some part
of this money and they created a club
the club of the the club that has
the club of the 13 and you you have here
a testimony of Jean Bernard later he
explained that they were thinking about
the modernization of French medical
research in inodes uh he had only one
woman among the uh the the the 13.
no okay yeah sorry
uh I forgot to to pass the so
so he explained that there was only one
woman among the uh the the the the the
this group and I like this uh this code
in fact it is likely that we were only
10 at the beginning and that the name of
13 is only a Balzac reference you know I
am a bad sex man well that's the kind of
uh Elegance of this uh of of this man it
was later at the Academy Frances and you
see also the
um it's the the the the the feeling of
these people to to be creating a Kind of
Revolution they were meeting in a small
house there it was not a conspiracy at
all but they had the thing to create
something for the future and something
very innovative
this club was transformed in 1953 in the
association club Bernard based on the
name of the famous doctor of 19th
century and this Association was
explicitly dedicated to fundraising
the organized fundraising in the on a
private
uh
organization and they were able to
finance the first really
true I will say authentic Laboratories
in the French system I bought astitute
pastor but
they were able in 1956 to finance a
modern Laboratories for research without
the money coming from the government the
money coming from the government was
going to ask the national Legion where
research were developed about public
health very important things but the I
will say the the high level research in
terms of medical research was developed
in these Laboratories with some success
with John Bernard and John Berger we
were able to to develop iPads
I have no no time for that but there
will be the the the the the main
organizers of the French research in the
in the in the future well so this period
is already a success but a fragile
success because the the global
organization of the French research is
performing
more and more but at the same time the
evolution of science is
is tremendous
um
at the end of the 1950s and the
beginning of the 1960s I think that you
have a kind of
a Nexus in terms of transformation of
the relationship between research the
hospital health and so on this is based
on two main scientific
developments scientific and
technological development
very quickly you will remember the
discovery of DNA of course in 1953 and
the development of computer
was developed since the I would say the
end of the second world war but the real
beginning of computer in everyday life
not every day but for
companies for middle-sized Laboratories
and so on I will send accessible
computers the IBM 360 in 1964 and all
the other computers which followed and
this the conjunction of a digitalization
of the equipment and of course of the
DNA concept and all that created
something new and the progress done by
the French research in terms of
organization money and so on in the
1950s was not able to meet the new
challenge that was created by this uh
higher level need in science in
equipment in technology
that does not mean that the uh the
result was was not already on the table
you will remember the uh for instance
the Jacques Mundo uh research but
something new was
was needed
um I I'm always impressed uh when I read
the papers of the period 1950
8
1961 by the capacity of the French
society French political system to
change drastically the organization of
the country
uh it's not a secret at prison time
France has some problem in Oregon in
order to to change things and uh when
you see all the project we wear uh put
on the table and transformed in reality
in some months at the end of the 1950s
at the very beginning of the fifth
Republic It's amazing
two men were engaged in this uh first
part of this chain it was
Roberto is one of the key figure of this
history it was during the the occupation
uh resistance it was a Jewish he tried
to adapt his comportment at the very
beginning of the occupation and finally
understood that martial petan government
was completely going to collaboration so
he entered the resistance and it was at
the in the at the head of a very
important part of the resistance
organized by uh by doctors in previous
and in other places in France and after
the war it was the kind of reference the
person of reference for all the reforms
he had a strong influence from a
political point of view we used it on I
will say fair fair in a fair way to to
to try to improve things and he decided
to
propose to the government of Charles de
Gaulle a revolutionary
plan of reorganization of French
hospital
with the the purpose of joining the
research and the hospital
the other part of the reform was also to
allow the French doctors to have a
private
clientele customers to have private
because I don't know if customers
passions
drivers Private Practice inside the
public Hospital
so it was a very uh some people we say
it's scandalous or some other we say it
was very efficient yes I would say it
was pragmatic how to have the best
doctors in
the public Hospital working there doing
research so the reform
will organize that and we are still in
this system in France with some kind of
adaptation and
you call that a learning hospital or
Research Hospital yeah yeah that's
that's the same kind of organization of
of course it was inspired by the uh iOS
American system with the specificity
based on the Social Security and so on
of the private part of the inner public
hospital with be a little bit strange
and the other
part of the evolution was the creation
of course in 1964 July of the in Sam as
the two nationality is
in fact this new Institution
was a kind to be simple of major of
merger between the astituational
decision on the one hand and the
association club burner on the other end
that's not an official figure the
official figure was to transform the
institutional decision in in CERN but
the reality is that you will have in the
new in some different communities coming
from different organization the enh
culture and the association called
Vienna culture the way to use new
equipment and so on and so
you have also to understand that the
creation of Instagram is the part of a
bigger plan in order to give a new
impulse to the development of Science in
France science more connected to uh
industry to military issues to ads and
things like that so A Research directly
connected to the need of the society and
these different institution was created
you have the chronology I hope on the
screen and the insem is in the middle of
that you you will see mostly
the other things are important but it's
a it's very specific to to friends the
creation of central nationality special
Center for space Studios and the incense
and after the insem The Institute
nationality on a formatic and automatic
French computer science research center
so you have really a new generation of a
center for research 1945 and Iran that
was I will study uh the the first we
have about still about
telecommunication and so on if you have
space you have Earth and you have
computers and I think that you have a
systemic understanding of that which is
very very important
so insom was created with the different
people coming through from different
Origins and you you have to to keep in
mind that the the the the the the
modahan the big Professor coming from
the association club we are not used to
to work in a a big organization they
were used to work in the hospital in
their service they were kind of King in
the in their uh in the in their service
they were used to to have a more or less
direct connection with some funding and
they they had to uh adapt to a bigger
organization and at the very beginning
they thought that they would they would
be naturally the leaders of this new
organization bad things uh will uh will
will be a little bit more complex that
will be my last part the organized
organizing and professionalizing medical
research
uh the the 10 first use of the history
of Instagram are really fascinating when
you go in the archives you see that
these people of the uh
um an incredible coming commitment to
organize something not from scratch but
the enh was not able at all to give the
uh the fundamental Organization for the
future it was an old-fashioned
organization and the new Instagram has
to create something radically new
connected to International
research and connected to the new way to
do science
what helped was firstly the
um the budget
uh
this kind of of budget not here for uh
in a hedge which is in a very good
position in terms of evolution of the
budget but in France at present time to
see uh that between 1962 and 1966 the
budget
passed from 28 million to 17 2 Millions
is uh really incredible that was not
very uh classical in this period
so you have a in the development of uh
of the budget but also uh the uh new
people coming into the institution
before interim medical research was uh
performed was organized by doctors in
the hospital
since the nine since 1964 or at least
maybe
67 68 you have newcomers people who are
sometimes Physicians but they don't they
do not want to go to the hospital they
do not want to have a client customers
they want to do 100 research in a
laboratory and they want to to to to go
to research and they have the
possibility within CERN to have a status
of a 100
full-time researcher they will be paid
only to do research they will not have
to go to the hospital or to teach
they are not in the University they are
doing research 100 percent of their time
two communities which are beginning to
develop in in CERN you have I will say
it's a caricature but it's a it's too
simple but the whole generation based on
the hospital the uh and the new
generation the kind of Legion Turk Young
Turks who thought that they were able to
change everything very quickly and the
first clash between these two groups was
you can imagine in 1968 when the insan
was on strike and that new figures
appeared in the in the landscape young
people who were in the protest we were
at the head of the unions unions in the
in in the medical world that was
incredible for researchers and that they
were in the Indians and I will notice
that but on in this group you will find
later all the leaders of the instrument
I would say the 1980. so you you have
really a a social laboratory of what is
research and how is organized socially
at a research inference and maybe in a
supporter of the world you have here a
draw of General dugul Amit sin in
medicine like everywhere we do not want
any more gone back home Big Bus
so in the 1970s uh constant Burke was at
the head of interim decided to organize
the institution a very systematically
and I think that the way he he does with
this problem was in a way very modern
he trying to find a balance between what
what he called the
humus policy the uh uh uh
budget which were coming back every year
on a regular basis in order to give a
stability to team of research and at the
same time an objective policy on with
project Finance dedicated to specific
projects that can be very that you you
can think that it's very classical at
present time of course but in this
period that was very modern to write it
to explain it and to say to the
researchers you will have to balance
between these two these two objectives
you would be also uh I think really
Amazed by the lecture of the by the
reading of the of the papers of this
period I read very very precisely all
the debates which were uh uh developed
between different actors about uh the
evaluation of researchers and the use or
not of bibliography
uh it's to use bibliography and maybe
that was a good thing I'm speaking I'm
talking in a as an historian
the use of bibliography of bibliometrics
I was not at all obvious
it was for a big part of the community
completely stupid
why to use that we know someone is good
someone is that good we we have to read
if we want to understand the quality of
the research maybe it's not so stupid
but finally
the biblio metrics were organized a
service was created very soon compared
to the other part of the French research
community and on this based I think that
insan was a kind of pioneer Pioneer why
because the the researchers were
directly connected sooner I think that
not all but a big part of the researcher
dealing with other subject in France
they were connected to International
research
compared to the field of research
medical research is really connected to
international issues already in the
1970s
at least from the point of view of
friends
so
um
Berg was able also and it's uh it's
maybe a little bit trivial but to
organize secretaries to organize the the
way people were working together
things very basic but which were very
important in order to give to the
researchers a good kind at a good
environment for research
another point in the in this period was
the uh the way insom was able to create
new Institute of research new center of
research in different parts of the
country it was very important in France
in the 1970s to create a new balance
between Paris and the country and the
regime like we said so the the major
figure of the history of insan were able
to create new Laboratories sometime from
from scratch like in Marseille or
sometime on the basis of every old
research like in Strasbourg which were
very important part of the of the of the
system Leong of course Lil and so on and
you have this uh dissemination of the
activity of insem that was very positive
in order to find money because the
government was encouraging institutions
which we are creating new Laboratories
outside Paris so that was clever and
that was also connected to to
universities like Montpellier and so on
the all-new Medical University
already in this period the connection
with International research was
important I iPath
well some statistics the researchers
between 1970 and 1980 uh almost double I
will say the administrative staff
it's completely the contrary now the
administrative staff is declining and
it's a problem I would say well that's
not the point
1917-1980 the budget four times more and
the programs the programs it's the
statistic very important that shows you
that comparing to the global budget the
part of the dedicated program to
specific issues were much more developed
at the end of the destiny that at the
beginning
now I have a few minutes remaining I
will go to uh to to to my conclusion
um
um I will say firstly that
um the uh the evolution of Instagram is
very interesting in terms of
um connection to a more global history
of Science and Technology I will
underline very specifically what I uh
said about the DNA and the computer you
cannot understand this theory of
biomedical research if you do not
understand the story of computer science
uh DNA is wonderful but without computer
you can do nothing and I'm I'm uh I will
say part of a school of the history of
technology using the term of large
technical system
of course on the other end social
construction of technology and we think
that you cannot understand the history
of science without understanding the
story of technology and it's not the old
fashioned way to see your science and
then you have technology but of course
through the concept of technoscience the
dialectic between the evolution of
technology and the evolution of science
it's obvious in a in physics in medicine
and so on so that's that's the first
conclusion this period of the uh I will
say the creation of the in some is also
important in terms of
the um
the
conflict
we always have positive conflict between
the the bench and the clinic and this
conflict is not over it's the tension uh
inside the medical community and you can
see at least in prison timing in France
I don't know how it is in the United
States that there's different Logics are
still uh conflicting with different
personalities
with different organization and as an
Eastern I think that that would be an
ever-ending story that's the matter in
fact of the system you cannot stabilize
things that will be over and over some
in some periods one part of the system
will be more dynamic in another period
the other part will be more Dynamic it's
the motor of the uh of the evolution
um
I will show you also a very short
statistic about prison time if you have
question to to about that you have to
ask uh to to to Philippe is he wants to
give you more information but you see
that in CERN finally he was able to
develop a big organization in at present
time more than almost 14 000 people
working with different status
a big part connected to International
cooperation and a big
activity in Publications
but to really conclude my my choke I
will uh I will come back to uh the 1960s
I would feel confused as a French uh
Scholars if I was in the United States
without
quoting Michelle Foucault
it's uh it's a must
I have not finished the Nissan's direct
clinic but I try
in birth of the clinic wrote in 1963 so
the year before the creation of
insurance
um we shall no longer only the medicine
shall no longer only be the Corpus of
healing techniques and the code
knowledge they require it will also
Encompass a knowledge of human health
and of course this move from the study
of disease to the study of Health a
fundamental of in the evolution of
research and I think that with this
connection with hospital with this
connection to with laboratory insom was
able
this story is not a mystery of successes
but there are statistics and they are
successes in them was able to uh to push
in this direction and to help friends to
enter in the kind of modernity in the
management in the development of medical
research thank you very much
[Applause]
this connection between uh Rockefeller
and the Marcel Institute for Hygiene I
find that fascinating do you have a
sense on what percentage they
contributed to that Institute in terms
of money and why grants are they in
other countries too maybe you can repeat
that question if Dr sector
instead of getting given like
what
okay well I will not answer directly
because I have not the statistics on the
uh on my on my paper the the real
Specialist of this question is is my
co-author for the book about Essentials
a part of the elements I used in my
presentation were based on on his
research I will give you the uh the
references of small articles that is
online
um
I don't think that in terms of
percentage the amount that was uh uh put
in the system by the Rockefeller
Foundation was so important I don't know
but what was important was the capacity
of having this money of very specific
points where money was really needed and
that was that gave a kind of flexibility
and a new impulse for new things so it's
not only a question of quantity it's
also question of quality of and
flexibility of the money but I'm not I'm
not able to answer precisely to your
question let me ask you began with
pictures of Lynette and Pasteur as the
paragons of 19th century French medical
research but yet I sense there's actual
Claude Bernard who is the model and I
wonder why you don't include him as a
Jew and whether he's not really the
model or how interim developed yeah
Claude Bernard is a complete consensus
cloudburner is not involved in I will
say in this tension between the clinic
and the bench that so the these two
figures he did both yeah so that's why
well you it was not connected to my
problematic but I I could include
burnout with the association club Banner
who was of course of course scorpionized
is a key key element in the development
of medicine and and research inference
of course
yeah I have two questions uh once
related to the Rockefeller foundation
and that's question is why was
Rockefeller foundation so interested in
France and giving money to France
instead of to other U.S or other
European institutions and the second
question was you mentioned that France
was rather
far behind in science infrastructure and
training and why was that I mean they
were right next door to Germany and they
had England just to the north why why
were they behind
well it's uh it's a complexia too
complex question for the the first one
I've known strong answer again about
Rockefeller Foundation
what I will say is that this this
connection was organized well before
second world war even during first World
War I think that maybe the origin was
during the first World War I am not sure
but uh we have a specialist of first
world war maybe you will help me to to
answer but
before the United States entered the war
in 1917 already a private organization
tried to help France to to stand the the
the the the the the the the problems of
the war to have children
um to help a woman who were alone and so
on so there is a kind of charity for for
for friends helped by personal
connection
uh and the second question is the is the
research of my life I cannot uh really
find the the answer I studied a lot of
subject about mostly the interwar period
um
well
concerning medicine really friends
French research was at at a low level
globally but with some brilliant person
which we were able to to to do Brian and
things but the organization was not at
all at their level but you can find in
other fields some private companies some
um
for instance in electronics in
electronics the the the the French
industry was at a fair level before
Second World War uh cooperating a lot
with American industry and so on so
maybe I give two negative picture of uh
French situation but what is sure is
that the state was not able to organize
research and
I published recently a paper about the
activity of the Academy of Science in
France during the first World War
and the Academy of Science tried to
imagine a way to organize scientific
research in France after a first World
War
the analysis was Germany is stronger
than hers because they have science this
analysis was already done after the
Franco Prussian war in 1870. the science
the Germans the Persian scientists were
the real winner of the war that nothing
was really well organized between
1970 and 1914. so during first world war
the the the the the the the the the
academicians were thinking we will
organize something new after the war and
so like very often in France in this
period at least after a period of
mobilization after to organize things
that was a long long term and in the
1920s the you can find some uh
uh initiative coming from the states the
States was not so developed in France in
the 1920s
and finally it was in the 1930s that the
the the the the fact that the state had
to organize the research in France was
completely a commitment
occurred and it's not only the war it's
the depression
uh the the research was understood as a
as a tool in order to prepare the the
defense of the country but many many
scientists were not able in the 1930s to
think about the preparation of the war
you know the first world war was a real
traumatism for France and the pacifism
was much more important in the
scientific Community than in other part
of the population but to to to create
new activities and that's why the
seneres was created in 1939
so you you you have this uh you have
debate NeverEnding debates in the French
historian Community about the the
temporalities of this uh of this uh new
impulse in French research if your goal
is to explain that you know how the goal
arrived in Paris in 1944 and decided
that French research would would
developed well it's a part of the story
but as you see I shall be turned of not
Marshall Peter but some people in in his
administration decided to create
research and the seniors was created
before the war so the the the
explanation for the fact that this
decision were not taken
I will set the beginning of the 20th
century I cannot I cannot tell you one
of the biggest problem was the lack of
connection between the university and
the private companies that's the that's
really a a big point for many reasons
cultural reasons
I I have two questions if I may one is
as an American MD who spent quite a lot
of time in insert
one of the things that I find concerning
which you didn't talk about at all is
the very low percentage of MDS who
actually have research positions within
interim I think the percentage is three
percent three to five percent if I'm not
mistaken so I was wondering if you could
comment on that
at present time you mean yes
I cannot tell you maybe Philip could
answer is more aware I know the
percentages I'm just I just think
that if we're talking about the future
of Instagram and the future of medical
research I think that's something that's
important to take into consideration so
I just
yeah yeah I cannot answer about that and
my second question is someone who's also
spent lots of time on in certain
commissions is
I disagree that bibliometric
analyzes are the way to go with a
decision on how to hire people
I agree
but you rate okay that's fine you raised
that as something that was very positive
as a new yeah position and instrument
why and I have to say having been in
commission that I think it's a very
dangerous way because you end up taking
people who are doing things that are a
la mode and not necessarily the best
science which is not necessarily cited
as as much yeah I agree completely with
you personally about that
personality about that and uh I was at
the end of the of a commission in the
center rest during four years it was an
interdisciplinary commission we were
recruiting people dealing with
communication and we were a group of
computer scientists
linguistic philosopher and so on and I I
was I was at the head of this commission
and the the very first day when people
met
Alf of the group opened the computer
and when a new candidate was presenting
is our project in front of us they were
typing on their laptop
what are you saying well we are checking
the impact factor
oh well you have no impact factor in
history we try to read books we do not
use bibiometrics so you will not do that
with me
and we decided to well the control
yeah but we decided not to use a Barbara
metric I will say a brutal
bibliometrics but why I mentioned that
about these two refinson it's because it
was very interesting to see how a
community which was based on personal
relation well the the recruitment was
based on is my student he will go there
and so on how they try to change things
and the use of bibliometrics seemed to
them and now unfortunately maybe but in
the biomedical Community it's still
important they decided to try to use
that and the exchange between people are
a good picture of uh what was the State
of Mind of this different people at this
period and that was very interesting to
see the
the retina
the the words used to to to criticize
that other questions maybe I could make
one comment and response further to
Michelle's question uh the Rockefeller
foundation in contrast to the
Rockefeller Institute or later the
Rockefeller University was a
pioneer of global Health from the 1920s
on and I'm not quite sure how that
relates to the Rockefeller family itself
but for example not only in France but
the creation of the Peking Union Medical
College in the 1920s in Beijing even the
small country which I visited several
times Albania had delegations from the
Rockefeller Foundation during the 30s so
it it pioneered Global
support of medical research in France of
course Very importantly and that
probably isn't and also it's generally
considered the real Foundation of
molecular biology within the United
States at Caltech and other institutions
so the importance of the Rockefeller
Foundation I think is not fully
appreciated to this day sure
at the same time thank you
other
commentary if not thank you very much we
very much